OK, so I'm sure by now you all know what's
going on with voting in November.
We should vote.
The act of voting itself, whether you vote
in person or not, has become highly politicized.
My take is everybody should vote.
You have the opportunity to participate in
deciding who's going to lead our country and
not just talking about Trump versus Biden.
I'm talking about the local level.
I'm talking about the state level.
And you should exercise that right.
And you should have a say.
So people have written to me and they've said,
David, with all of this confusion about absentee
versus vote by mail, please explain how to
vote by mail.
So first of all, what we're talking about
for November is expanded absentee ballot access,
or you might call it in some states, universal
absentee voting in states that have decided
to send ballots out.
They go only to registered voters.
They don't go to undocumented immigrants.
They don't go to children.
Do not fall for those talking points.
Each state has its own rules.
So you have to know the rules of your state
or commonwealth.
So, first of all, figure out the rules in
your state.
Go to the NASA s Web site page called absentee
and early voting.
We're linking to that page in the description
to the YouTube clip for this story you put
in your state.
For example, when I put in Massachusetts,
it takes me to the Massachusetts secretary
of the commonwealth page with information
on how to get an absentee ballot.
Now, Massachusetts sent out absentee ballot
applications automatically.
I received the application.
If I plan to vote by mail, which I do, I fill
it out.
I send it back in.
And then at some point after the September
1st primary, once we know exactly who will
be on the ballot in November, I will get the
actual absentee ballot, which is where I vote.
Now, this is not the situation in every state.
If you look at the Brookings map raiding states
on vote by mail, you will see that states
range in ratings from eight to F..
Right now, Alabama is the only state rated
F on absentee voting, while a bunch of states
get an A..
Including the three West Coast states, Utah,
Colorado, Hawaii and Washington, D.C., and
then a bunch of states get a B..
And this relates to the ease with which you
can access an absentee ballot in your particular
state.
Now, I wish I could tell you this is the one
way to do this, but each state runs things
differently.
So you actually do need to go and look at
your state's voting Web site.
Now, a few things to understand.
And again, your state's Web site will tell
you this.
If you're in the Commonwealth of Virginia
or the state of Florida or even the state
of Florida, as Trump says, the every state
and commonwealth has a Web site that will
explain this to you.
In some states, every registered voter will
get a ballot automatically.
Perfect.
Just confirm your registered.
You can do that on the USA dot gov page.
Confirm you are registered to vote.
We're also linking to that.
If you're registered and you're in a state
that's sending out ballots to every registered
voter.
Beautiful.
In other states, every registered voter will
be sent an application for a ballot which
you have to fill out and send in in order
to request the actual ballot be sent to you.
That's what I did in Massachusetts, for example,
in some states, you have to choose to go and
apply for an absentee ballot.
Now, typically, I think there are some states
where it can be.
Online in other states, you have to send some
physical piece of mail to request the absentee
ballot in some states.
Everybody is allowed an absentee ballot.
In other states, you have to give a valid
reason for why you want to vote absentee.
And depending on your state saying I'm afraid
of catching Corona virus is considered a valid
reason.
Now, in other states, there's still a fight
going on about that.
So you would have to look at the reasons that
are considered valid reasons for requesting
an absentee ballot in your state and match
it to your situation.
I'm not suggesting anybody lie, but examine
what the valid reasons are and determine whether
any of them match your circumstances.
It's tragic that this is what's going on.
But all we can do, given that voting in some
states starts in four and a half weeks, is
to go to your state's Web site.
If you have to request something, do it now
and stay on top of this.
This really isn't difficult.
And I understand when you hear, well, am I
getting a ballot or am I getting an application?
Do I have to print the application or can
I fill it out online?
I get it.
We have 50 different systems in the United
States.
All of the links you need are in the description
to this YouTube video clip.
If anybody you know, is at all confused about
how to vote by mail.
Send them this clip.
We did a story on the bonus show where we
discuss that a whole bunch of people, including
and particularly young people, aren't sure
how to vote by mail, how to request an absentee
ballot or whether they will get one automatically.
That's exactly the confusion we are trying
to resolve here.
Figure out what's going on in your state using
the links provided in the description for
this YouTube clip.
It is not difficult.
You have a right to vote in most states.
Now you have a right to vote absentee.
If you go through the right process, take
advantage of things that are offered to you,
because the stakes, quite frankly, could not
be higher.